hey guys we're back with part 2 of our
Samsung collaboration so well fact we
got to team up with Samsung and brought
over a film crew and they got to see us
transform our living room and it was
really fun to share the moment together
to revamp our living room because I
don't know like our schedules are so
busy we never actually have time to do a
whole lot of stuff together other than
to like share a meal or share a weekend
we go out and have fun but I like to do
stuff productively at home you usually
do stuff like that separately and I
don't know it offered a opportunity for
us to bond together yeah it's true
because it took us like half a year to
finally use this living room so that was
I was thankful for that and thank you
guys for your continuous love and
support hope you guys enjoyed this video
thank you love you I know I'm just
kidding I can do that I am this is nice
you know it's also cool is that this
actually you pop it out you can use it
for like hand stuff this is like that
this is if this came in all black this
would be like Batman's vacuum everything
is attachable it's like alright downs
damage let it go careful oh sorry
good morning so guess what guys today we
have samsung here with us to power up so
guess what we don't have to hold the
camera we have a show right over there
so today we're going to be fixing up our
living room finally we've been living
here for about six months and we've been
dying thank you you've been dying to fix
this place up
powering up for a busy day of moving
furniture so I actually wanted to hire
someone to do this because it was
enjoying me crazy but Casey convinced me
that I can just do it on my own and that
I have an eye for this stuff so finally
I dug up the courage to go shopping so
we went shopping recently and I bought a
whole bunch of cool stuff to set up the
living room dress it up really nice and
I'm really excited for you to see
everything cuz you haven't seen anything
that I bought tips always harp on the
fact that she doesn't know what her real
passion and like true talent in life is
I'm like you're so good at organizing
and like you're the person that's giving
me at home like I'm the kind of guy that
I could live out of cardboard box and be
completely fine with it but we might not
live in Farber box no more now so yeah I
think you should have a little more
confidence in the fact that you're
really good at interior designing thank
you baby
I lied alright it's the battery yeah I
think this is a very so this is the
Samsung power stick vacuum that they
actually sent over for us to try out
it's from NASA not Samsung it looks
crazy it even looks super futuristic and
it's super lightweight too isn't it so
that's power to baby up step it up let
me know what do you think Oh
Oh
[Music]
picks up everything it's so light - it's
so weird to not have a cord on this hand
so sweet cuz it's so smooth I like how
it just swivels - is this what's the
purpose of these things what do you mean
they're for decorating didn't you look
at her box
you should put stuff in it oh yeah we
can't put stuff in it but the purpose is
for decorating oh you're such a guy
that's how guys are like what's this for
UNICEF purpose purpose to tell time no
purpose
what do you mean no purpose it has
decorative purpose other than that what
do you think this does and it's a cat
toy cat toys so probably good only good
one purple why are you criticizing
everything I bought cuz I'm looking at
alike I don't know what this is man I
was so excited for you to actually be
like oh this is cool I wouldn't have
thought it and then here you are making
me feel bad for everything I'm not
trying to make you feel bad this this is
cool this is like four fruit in it huh
well this is actually meant for these
globe I like that I don't know what to
do a button I don't think I would've
bought anything
oh this one goes over here yeah
oh my bed on the other side here switch
oh it's fun try more stuff
I like all this stuff that you got yeah
I like that you got fake plants too
yes so the reason why I actually wanted
to get fake plants is our cats will go
insane if we actually had real dirt and
like real leaves gonna eat that's why I
wanted to get the fake ones cuz I'm like
if we get real plants imagine they're
gonna dig up because even like the the
neighborhood cat they'll come up here in
the patio and then they're just like
digging up all the dirt we need to get
fake plants for sure because there's so
much open windows and like natural
lighting coming in and then once we
actually bring in the element of green
and life and like it just feels more
alive in here sure we're second
ourselves out though a fake plant I know
growing up my mom spent a lot of time
and effort into like making the house
look nice and stuffy nose in the help in
the home that they live in now this
experience does remind me a lot of my
childhood because my mom is well she
loves to decorate the home and she
actually even worked with this one
company that would sell this kind of
like home stuff I don't know what it was
called but she would work for one of
those and like every day she'd come home
with like a new item to put on the wall
or like to put on the coffee table or
whatever so we always had like these
useless like decorative things so like
like those things over there
yeah I know like this think I make fun
of home but they actually add a lot to
the feel of the room you do yeah and
then I feel like you say that I'm like a
natural-born carrier than everybody
think it was my mom nurturing that
unintentionally cuz she would do that so
I just observed and that's kind of how I
just ended up liking him to do this
stuff I don't know that's how anyone's
hobbies or talent or skill sets come
into place you just observe and you have
a good interest in it yeah that was like
the perfect combination for you at that
time
well what about and then for your like
filming oh I know why cuz you're dead
you would always walk around with
cameras right my dad loved cameras you
loves capturing of it it's you know
what's so crazy is the fact that I
actually still have the footage of like
my baby footage of myself yeah now what
about watching those video I look back
at those like
and my dad was talking to the camera he
was talking to I was like he was
vlogging crab this is like 1988 my dad
was already vlogging we didn't even know
that existed you know that's all I never
see the shots of him like filming
himself in the mirror and you can see
they're like way better yeah and that's
a very like modern-day thing to do I
feel like back then people like yeah if
you had a camera every we're just kind
of like awkward right yeah so I feel
like my parents influence our interests
yeah
[Music]
you
just finished the living room I think it
looks fantastic axons coming home right
now
curious that's to see what he's gonna
say okay hold your eyes closed oh sorry
hey are you okay did your trip no you're
good okay I'm ready for this
we're really hard all morning okay ready
three two one whoa you like it I love it
now we could close home right baby yeah
I should get Josh to come over in one of
these haha I know he would probably have
a good water he would definitely why
didn't slip